oh my god I'm actually shooting in the
morning and there's a lens flare because
the light is morning light and it's so
goddamn beautiful can you see what like
that thing that's not I didn't put that
there
nature did good morning and welcome to
your Monday morning pep talk it is in
fact Monday mornings because I was too
tired to shoot this video last night
that's okay
pep talk you're gonna have a great week
this week I just wanted you to know that
unless you don't have a great week this
week that's okay
pep talk see this little ones flurry
thing and now it's a beautiful floating
monocle Thank You nature pep talk what's
the one thing that you really want to
accomplish in your life this week just
choose one simple thing you can do it
and if you don't do it you didn't do it
maybe that's what you wanted to do not
do the thing that you thought you wanted
to do pep talk do you wanna ask out
Karen no no one wants to ask out Karen
pep talk get that promotion use your
brush it's grace I got my promo you can
all show me that talk what did it pep
talk don't mess with the best you'll get
the rest sleep always sleep pep talk you
were so putting black eyeliner on your
eyelids and then they don't match so you
just pile a more more black eyeliner
until you eventually look like the
Jersey girl stereotype you once made fun
of
it's okay pep talk I'll it rolled my
shirt this morning cuz I have dog hair
on it def pop top yes I do own a lint
roller sometimes looks are deceiving pep
talk I own a normal size my roller and a
tiny travel size apparently I [ __ ]
hate lint laptop oh do you want money
get it so Hardware cord cutting corners
what happens when you cut a corner
things come full circle pep talk
that was me
turning Dustin to a depth than the dove
exploded and caught on fire Scarlett
Johansson like Scarlett your buzzer
tick-tock
you're not this girl congratulations pep
talk what are you selling don't forget
to have faith in yourself
whoever doesn't like coffee can suck a
dick pep talk hmm burn me once shame on
you
burn me twice you probably a fire and I
should call hey Doc hey did your
beautiful Monika changes oh look at oh
wow
Wow can't right here cool pep talk
basically I just wanted to spend this
morning giving you a little
encouragement to get you through the
rest of your week you can do anything
that you put your mind to that is not
true you can do it you might not do it
well but you can do it trying is half of
the war on drugs
keep kids off the street - your boys
boys are cool cool in the game say no to
ganks I don't know I forgot to tell you
guys that there's new camp Takota merch
on camp Takota calm it's really pretty
shirts of which I don't have here and
it's you're not worth the middle finger
shirts go get a pep talk